facebook can we talk about 55 years old
i love the five five especially when you
double it up and you're 55 because at 55
years old you were told when you were 16
15 40 years ago that 55 was [ __ ]
finished retired go to florida wrap it
up people were dying at 60 commonly you
know 40 50 years ago but 55 year olds on
facebook today we need to talk about
this like you're going to live for
another 40 years
and this whole concept of i wish i did
this or i wish i did that well don't
wish go do it this video is for 55 year
olds and older for that matter this this
works for 65 and definitely works for
45.
stop crying about what you wish you did
and go do it
you have so much life left we are so bad
at understanding the time of course
there's accidents of course you might
have lost a friend last week life is
short life is also long and for a lot of
you you're going to be 89 and 92 and 94
and you're going to crush 55 to 65 and
65 to 75 and 75 to 85 so stop watching
this video and go do it